all right
david yeah david uh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
massachusetts
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were a kid
yeah
how was your childhood i'm not that
happy
what kind of stuff went on it's my fault
oh i had
well you know problems
what do you i mean what do you mean oh
i always felt like i didn't belong
certain groups always a misfit
always a misfit and what to tell me
about your parents they were
oh jesus nice people
very nice people i didn't treat them
nice
you were adopted or are you i'm adopted
you're adopted
yes and uh but but no traumatic events
nothing is more your you're
not you're the troublemaker sort of
um some things were my fault
maybe most of it but i had my problems
yeah and what do you know anything about
your but your
neighbors nothing and so
what kind of kid when you're in high
school what what kind of kid were you in
high school
message and so you went on your own at
what age
you went out on your own it would yeah
well i was 17 16
17. did you finish i got my ged you did
okay
and where'd you go from there oh
crappy jump one crappy job to another
what kind of jobs do you do dips walking
i worked on
i don't know if you remember them i went
to hayes and bigfoot
in boston they had these cafeterias
they're not around anymore
them and waldorf you remember foxes here
in san francisco
they had a whole group of them they were
owned by the
by the way by the same people it's kind
of
i guess they went out of style you know
these cafeterias
right i know they don't have them in my
own name well
so do you have uh family do you have
kids of your own no not dead
no ever married no never been in love
maybe
so you uh have even prison time for
anything no
stayed out of jail in prison i've been
in jail yes yeah
are drugs a part of your life what are
drugs a part of your life
no no yeah
well you're living here in the
tenderloin yes in san francisco you've
been here since when
1981. it's a long time yes and you're
staying in one of the hotels now
no he said apartment it's not a very
nice apartment but it's an apartment
and what do you do how do you support
yourself now mine is designed
so you're getting money from the
government yeah and uh were you ever
homeless
maybe at the longest maybe a month at a
time okay
and not very many times
so this this misfit outcast
image that you have of yourself do you
think that came from
from anything that happened in your
childhood or was it maybe your your
blood
parents or maybe something on you maybe
it's in my ancestry
yeah the fact that you're adopted kind
of
yeah but i don't think that's it yeah
what what's most what's the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
a lot of them i guess i'm going to keep
my mouth shut
you can learn a lot that's right i used
to be you know
kind of butt in convo people's
conversations number one they don't like
it
number two uh if you kind of keep quiet
you can learn something
that's very true i think yeah do you
have friends
um i have friends you know mainly you
know
from the soup kitchens i work in
do you feel like you were ever loved as
a child or
not really you know love is a strong
emotion but
no yeah is there anyone that you trust
oh several people i trust yeah that's
important to have too
are you happy not really yeah so so you
know
i don't think i don't think most people
are happy i agree with that yeah
but that's kind of what my channel is
about um what uh
what do you think gets in the way of
that more than anything for yourself or
for other people
just life itself i guess trying to get
along with other people
yeah do you wish you would have done
anything different about your life
yeah yeah any regrets i wish i kind of
got a job i don't know
a little more regular life you know
maybe have a girlfriend but nonetheless
that didn't work
what was the best time of your life
probably in the early in the 70s
what were you doing back then i was on
welfare but um
i don't know things worked for you you
met people
had three or four girls and didn't mount
anything but you know
the hell do you know 74 74.
do you see the world is a good place or
do you see it as is dangerous and
if you know how do you see the world
i think it's getting worse
but people in general you see them as
well
i mean you look i think we're growing
back into fascism
let's look at the hit in the philippines
brazil
they were not poland did you really keep
up with poland i don't
uh they had an election um there was
some guy that was kind of a fascist but
he lost out in the election
that i think that was good news but
russia
what else all these countries hungary
uh philippines brazil
you you ever keep up with the news in
these places they don't
yeah definitely
and who are you voting for this this
fall oh biden
well who will you probably yeah i'm
probably not going to vote i'll just
stay out of it
because i'm in california so guess who's
going to win
i think unfortunately there's a good
chance trouble
really yeah not california but not in
california but the rest of the country
i'll be too busy editing to get off my
ass and vote
but uh but you're happy here in
california
you think just in general it's probably
the only place i can live in
you you won't be going back to
massachusetts no no no no no
besides my uh sisters she's a doctor but
they live in the maryland anyway i keep
interacting with them
that's nice but they live in maryland so
i don't think anybody i know lives in
massachusetts
you ever do you ever want to get in
touch with your actual parents
um i used to i kind of given up giving
that up yeah
a big be dead by now let's favorite
probably not around now yeah
all right david well thank you so much
for talking with me okay and good luck
with the
whatever you do from here all right
thank you
you